all right joining us now author of March
to the majority Fox News contributor
former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich Mr Speaker let's get your
overarching reaction all of this I think
this is big news and I think that the
walls are closing in very tight on Joe
Biden used to be a hunter Biden scandal
now it's a Joe Biden scandal and he lied
repeatedly
yeah but I think first of all you
get out and look at the entire Forest it
is Barack Obama politicizing the justice
department covering up all sorts of
things setting a standard that if you're
on the left you're never going to be
prosecuted it's Hillary Clinton making
millions and millions of dollars in ways
that involve basically public policy
decisions that favor Russians and others
and then there's Joe Biden who looks up
and he says let me get this straight
the Justice Department's never going to
come after me Hillary has proven you can
make tons of money doing this stuff why
shouldn't we play and it's no question
in my mind everything the Biden White
House says now about this topic is a lie
it's just plain totally a lie but it has
to be a lie I mean you can't expect the
incumbent president to come out and say
you know
we had a bad period there and Hunter and
I stole a whole bunch of money from the
Russians the Chinese the kazakhs the
ukrainians the Romanians but you know we
needed the money I mean he needed a
Porsche I didn't have a really good
place to put my Corvette you can't
really blame me uh I meant well and gee
it just all kind of crept up what's he
gonna say these guys are if you watch
the movie the Irishman with De Niro you
got to flavor of this these guys are the
mob they are exactly like a mafia group
they operate in total dishonesty why
would you think they're going to tell
the truth
you know Hunter Biden at the time
remember the the barisma executive you
know they were pleading this you go back
to this December 4th 2015 call out of
Dubai to the White House and messages
leading into this they desperately need
help from D.C then Devin Archer brings a
very important point out that the brand
the Biden brand was what they were
selling I don't think they were selling
the brand of the crack addict or the guy
that had a proclivity towards women of
the night the brand was obviously Joe
Biden then Joe Biden's big lie repeated
often as president and as a candidate
that he never once talked to these
people and now we know he's up to his
eyeballs meeting these people calling
these people you know dozens and dozens
of occasions then you look at the money
what would they paying Hunter for if Joe
wasn't involved what were they paying
the grandchildren for in these in these
bank accounts or shell corporations
look if I understand the timing
correctly
um there's actually a phone call from
Dubai
to Joe Biden which Peter Schweitzer is
convinced was paid for by barisma and we
ought to get the records of that phone
as a test of their sincerity being
cooperative
within days
Joe Biden is on the an airplane
government U.S government plane to go to
Ukraine and as he himself says the video
is available I mean he says publicly to
the Council on Foreign Relations I went
there and I told him if they didn't fire
this guy they were going to lose a
billion dollars in foreign aid and by
God within six hours it was done this
this is Biden himself on tape saying
this to a public group well if you go
back and say let me get this straight
the people who had hired your son
call you from Dubai a few days later you
are in Ukraine doing exactly what they
requested because their fear was that
this particular prosecutor was going to
take them all down so they weren't just
buying the brand I think archers being
way too nice here they were buying an
access to get the vice president United
States who also by the way was
threatening to cut off Ukraine from
international monetary fund money you
take those pieces together that's pretty
close to straight outright bribery do
you see Biden getting impeached over
this
I think it may eventually become to that
which I think scary because the idea of
Kamala Harris replacing him is
terrifying I don't I don't know about a
conviction in it with a Democratic
Senate but we'll see the walls are
closing in very tightly on all of them
and I don't see a way out for them Newt
Gingrich thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else